It's
information gathering, which way to go?
Well, bye didn't come and we're going to the trash, but
it's only enough to talk about
it at the
party Soga short sleeves are only two days away Charlie, are you
happy? ni I wonder
if there's a
cocktail  I think it's unreasonable, but that
's my personal opinion.The actual plan is still in the future, so I think I should say something about it at this stage.
Strike not on the ground, it's
troublesome,
more of a sense of smell than dirt Actually, that plan is not officially included in the activities that will be carried out this time In other
words, it's just a goal in the distant future,
but climbing this village
Udo and the other members are also particular about it.
Don't you think I don't have to say it twice
?